what up space Fame goes in here from
anime uproar and I said I would do
another strength video if the mihawk
video got over five thousand likes and
it got over five thousand likes in less
than 24 hours that's amazing and so I'm
back at it with a Kaito video this time
if you enjoy seeing one piece videos on
this channel and want to keep them
coming
show some love for one piece by smashing
that like button and sharing this video
if we can get six thousand likes
I repeat six thousand likes on this
video I'll get started on the next
strength video ASAP make sure to leave
your suggestions for who you want me to
cover next in the comments if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos you can
follow anime up for audio on Spotify
Apple podcasts or wherever else you
listen to podcasts to get early access
to all of our content including one
piece
links in the description keep in mind
the way I do these videos as I look at
relevant manga evidence to help get a
sense of how strong the character in
question is so there tend to be manga
spoilers in these videos you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it Kaito is the leader of the
beast pirates and one of the Four
Emperors of the sea along with shanks
whom I covered in a previous strength
video big mom and Blackbeard he's been
called the king of the beasts
and even the strongest creature in the
world out of all living Yanko Kaito has
the biggest bounty currently at about
4.6 billion berries Kaitos introduction
is one of my favorites in all of anime
it's like the perfect introduction for
an overpowered character from sky island
which is 30,000 feet in the air a man
jumped down searching for a place to die
this man was not other than the young
Cole Kaito we are told by the narrator
that Kaido has pasted the feet as a
pirate on seven occasions and even been
caught by the Navy or enemy ships no
less than eighteen times he was tortured
time after time and lived as a prisoner
he was sentenced to death forty times
the dude was hanged but the rope snapped
he was put under the guillotine but the
blade cracked he was stabbed with a
spear but the spear broke Kaito sank
nine different prison vessels the
narrator tells us that none of these
people were able to kill Kaito not even
Kaito himself Kaito survives the 30
thousand feet drop from Sky Island even
though he hit into the ground he didn't
die he just got a splitting headache for
Kaito trying to kill himself is nothing
more than a hobby
that's how Opie this guy's presented to
be from the beginning even though he's
supposedly searching out that no one
could ever kill him not even himself now
last time I talked about Kaito so many
people were like why doesn't Kaito just
jump into the sea if he wants to die so
much he's a devil fruit user so that
should be the end of him if no one helps
him that's a good point there's a number
of possible explanations for this
perhaps by chance he just never happened
to end up drowning in the sea and he
never thought of doing so or what is
more likely in my view he doesn't want
to use the sea because that would feel
like cheating for him that's not a test
of kind of strength because all devil
fruit users no matter how strong or weak
they are would die from that it is
possible that Qaida wants to find a way
to die in a quote-unquote fair way where
despite his full strength he is killed
after he fails to die from jumping off
of sky Island he's annoyed that he
survived again and he enviously says
that old white beard did it right and as
we know a sick old white beard did die
in the battle at marine port then the
narrator gives us some crazy information
people say that in a one-on-one fight to
always bet on Kaito furthermore we are
told the following on land sea and air
out of every living thing in the world
this pirate is said to be the strongest
creature alive and quote so we are
offered a lot of relevant information
during this epic introduction Kaito is
presented as beatable but unkillable
since he lost as a pirate seven times
but no one was ever able to finish the
job after taking him prisoner he's
supposed to always be able to win
one-on-one but this implies that he can
be beaten perhaps even killed when
strong opponents team up against him and
perhaps use less straightforward tactics
in battle Kaito is like the extreme
version of me Hawk in the sense that
they're both bored because of their high
level of power
however while one is trying to fill that
boredom by finding a worthy Challenger
the others actively trying to kill
himself if we can believe the narrator
though one on one Kaito is presented as
being the strongest living thing which
should encompass all humans
all animals keep in mind the narrator
uses words like people say and this
pirate is said to be so it's not
presented as definitive objective truth
but rather as the common consensus among
people but you can't get that many
people agreeing that you're the
strongest living creature unless you're
extremely strong and no one has shown
any proof that they're stronger than you
so this title is definitely hype worthy
and not senseless since I mentioned that
Cato has the highest current bounty I
will also mention that white beard and
gol D Roger used to have bigger ones
when they were alive white beard had a
bounty of five point four six billion
berries while pirate king gol D Roger
had a bounty of five point five six
billion berries so even if we go buy
bounties alone there were people who
were considered more dangerous in the
past notably white beard was referred to
as the strongest man in the world before
and kaido's introduction as the
strongest living thing in the world took
place after white beards death so
there's no need to over bloah kaito
strength and call him without a doubt
the strongest person ever to live but
you also shouldn't be sleeping on his
strength as far as we know he could very
well be the strongest person alive right
now
at least in one-on-one fights over 38
years ago a young keidel was part of the
rocks pirates led by Captain rocks
before gol D Roger became the king of
the Pirates it was the era of the rocks
pirates and this was arguably the
strongest crew ever they lack
camaraderie and crew members would kill
each other which in my view spelled
their demise but in terms of pure power
the rocks pirates were insane three
future yangko were part of this crew
including Cato white beard and big mom
along with other legends like Shiki the
golden lion and the man who led them all
captain rocks himself obviously the
future yong-chol would go on to become
stronger than they were then
but you can bet they were still forces
to be reckoned with
according to Sengoku joined the god
valley incident something truly crazy
happened the pirate king gol D Roger
teamed up with the marine legend GARP
and together they broke apart the rocks
pirates they clearly didn't kill Kaido
big mom or white beard but they did win
somehow which is beyond impressive
considering how strong the rocks pirates
must have been just like Yanko shanks
kite
started on a very powerful crew then
like other former members of the rocks
pirates he established and built his
very own crew two years after Odin
returned to one Oh from his travels with
white beard and Roger
Kaido and his crew fought gecko Moria
and his crew in Cato absolutely
destroyed moriya's crew and moriya's
wanted revenge ever since finally five
years after he returned Odin decided it
was finally time to strike down Kaito
inner door chief remember he was strong
to begin with and he'd gotten a lot
stronger after traveling with white
beard the strongest man in the world and
Roger the Pirate King
Odin hoped the surprise attack a drunk
idol but because of the traitor kanjuro
Qaeda was ready for him Kaito had let on
and on pretending like he'd give him
what he wanted if he obeyed him but in
truth Kaito was buying time because he
sensed that his side was on a
disadvantage initially he felt that
initially it aden would have joined
forces with yoga role and the beast
pirates had to deal with all the samurai
and Yakuza together it would have been a
difficult battle because they had fewer
numbers so he gave Odin hope while he
was really just dividing the enemy's
numbers and gaining fighters Kaito calls
out Odin for being mighty but soft like
white beard and Roger
because Odin wanted to avoid bloodshed
he let himself be tricked Odin's
strength surpassed Cato's expectations
even then qaeda was viewed as invincible
but Odin gave him the X shaped scar he
has to this day when it seemed like Odin
had the upper hand
kudos Umi he gue dashi who had the clone
clone fruit disguise herself as a
hostage and qaeda took advantage of the
distraction he knocked out Odin with his
club in one hit Kaito was clearly
surprised though he was sweaty and
bloody it was nothing like Luffy and
Kyle's first fight in that regard
Odin definitely did a lot better than
gear for Luffy then Kaito promises to
release anyone who lasts the full hour
at the execution Odin laughs the full
hour while lifting his men above the
boiling oil to boot Kaito doesn't keep
his promise though he takes out a gun
and kills Odin by shooting him
interestingly enough though despite how
much Kaito is willing to deceive and
trick he does seem to have some sense of
honour before he kills Odin he says that
they will speak of him for years to come
and say that he died a spectacular death
Kaito clearly
spects Odin Kaito apologizes for how
kudos Umi he GU da Shi tricked olden and
tells him that he had her killed the
whole story with Odin tells us a lot
about Kaito Odin help prove that kaido's
body wasn't invincible and that even
Kaito is bothered by underhanded tactics
to a certain extent it bothers him that
he didn't beat Odin fair and square this
story also shows that Kaito is not just
a really strong stupid guy he can plan
rather than jumping into a fight when
his side was out of disadvantage he
found a way to trick his enemy into
waiting until he had the upper hand we
definitely don't see much of this aspect
of Kaito after 20 years now he's usually
drunk and seems like a meathead but this
story shows that he was capable of being
strategic deceptive and patient in the
past and perhaps he still is now Kaito
obviously should have gotten stronger in
the past 20 years but it's noteworthy
that while Odin seemed notably weaker
than white beard and Roger he was a
match for Kaito he even had the upper
hand before the distraction and Quaeda
wasn't confident enough to fight him
fairly again we're seeing chinks in the
strongest creatures armor here fast
forward all the way to the paramount war
we are told that qaeda was going to try
to attack white beard but shang somehow
managed to intercept him and send him
away in usual oda glory this event is
shrouded in mystery and we don't know
how shanks made him turn back his men
did not look like they were in a fight
when they arrived at marine fort
so chances are he talked idol out of it
perhaps he said he would side with white
beard if Kaito attacked him and Kaito
knew that that would be too much for him
and his crew still it's notable that he
was confident enough to attempt to kill
the one called the strongest man in the
world although black beard is the one
who ended up swooping in and even
getting white beards powerful devil
fruit by the way if you guys want to see
a video on black beard next let me know
in the comments because I'm absolutely
fascinated with the character I think
he's the biggest threat of all to Luffy
and I'll go into that in more detail if
you guys want to see that video
we know that doflamingo a strong warlord
was very scared of Kaito to the point
where law could use that fear in order
to manipulate him in a monumental
chapter Kaito and big mob clashed up to
this point we hadn't seen Yaya
seriously shanks and white beard had one
weapon clash and it split the heavens
but it wasn't really a fight the same
thing happened meaning the heavens also
split when Kaito and big mom clashed
if Kaito is the strongest creature in
the world then you might have expected
him to win out but interestingly enough
he didn't they fought for two days
without getting any serious injuries
before they decided to team up it was
one-on-one and keidel didn't win to be
fair he might have won if the battle
lasted long enough but it's not a clear
power distinction that's another
interesting thing about one-piece white
beard Roger and their crews clashed for
days without either one winning a kind
of and cusan fought for ten days before
a kind who came out on top this is the
world of one piece and it's what makes
it so interesting you don't have huge
power differences that make for short
fights you have a bunch of strong guys
and the stronger one will probably take
days or even weeks to beat the other as
long as the power difference isn't too
significant this is why I find it funny
when people try to say that luffy is
already the fifth emperor after the
fight and wanna finishes it may be a
different story but for now luffy should
not be called an emperor if we're being
fair the emperor sent the clash equally
possibly for days they are so well
matched and powerful that their clash
has split the heavens as we've seen with
shanks and white beard and Kaido and big
law in contrast luffy versus Kaito part
1 was nowhere close to that Luffy
released so many attacks at Kaito and
Kaito got up like it was nothing then in
a split second he moved in and hit luffy
with his spike club one hit was all it
took to completely take luffy out of
commission
even though luffy was using gear for
with it's incredible defense afterwards
Kaito doesn't view Luffy as any kind of
threat he doesn't finish him off
preferring to send him to jail in the
hopes that he'll join his crew and he
just pieces out to get drunk again did
it take days or weeks no it took one hit
so Kaito is clearly way way stronger
than Luffy from what we've seen so far
and that brings us to the present where
Luffy law and Kidd along with samurai
Yakuza and their crews are going to try
to take down Kaito and big mom if you
didn't already realize how hyped this
confrontation will be then you
definitely should after this video Luffy
wills no match for Kaito before and now
he's going to
have to also take on as far as we know
equally strong big mom Kaito appears to
have a mythical zone devil fruit that
lets him change into a huge eastern
dragon that reminds me of Shenron from
Dragon Ball Z or an extremely powerful
Pokemon he can move through the air and
destroy huge buildings from a distance
with heat blasts now so I cover all my
bases this devil fruit hasn't been named
so some fans have theorized that Kaito
might be a dragon with a prehistoric
human fruit something like a strong
caveman we don't know for sure but it is
interesting that Kaito always has those
horns coming out of his head
but whatever turns out to be the
circumstances of his mysterious devil
fruit powers he's clearly very strong
big mom also laughed at the idea that
someone like Luffy could beat him and
Kaito seems to be a lot less cautious
than he was in the flashbacks from 20
years ago
he's usually drunk all the time and he
doesn't consider Luffy to be any kind of
threat this is probably the greatest
thing that the straw hats have going for
their side Kaito has no doubt gotten
stronger over the past 20 years but he
also seems to have become more careless
he's sure of his own superiority and
that may create an opportunity for
victory
if qaida was cautious enough to kill
Luffy like he killed Odin then this new
war would probably not be happening
especially not on this scale one on one
based on the evidence we have so far I
would put Kaito below prime white beard
and Goldie Roger
and around the same level as the other
yong-chol who all appeared to be pretty
close although if I had to put money on
it I'd say that Kaito would eventually
be big mom in a one-on-one fight though
it would clearly take a long time many
days or even weeks for the battle to
finish shanks is always a wild card
though because as we've seen he goes out
of his way to avoid showing his strength
while Kaito drunkenly beats people up
and destroys cities we've never seen
shanks resort to violence he let a petty
mountain bandit insult him and spilled
beer on him and let him get away with it
because of this aspect of shanks his
personality it's possible that Kaito is
considered stronger than him because
shanks goes out of his way to not show
off and to downplay his own power that
would also explain why his bounty is
lower than kaido's and big moms buy keep
in mind this is speculation and at this
point it probably makes more sense to
assume that kya
is stronger one-on-one until we get
evidence to the contrary I think
Blackbeard and Kato would also be an
interesting matchup I think people
underestimate Blackbeard's power this
dude was able to hide in white beard
shadow for decades while he brought his
master plan to fruition Blackbeard is
very conscious of what he's doing and I
think he has the lowest bounty of a
young Co to an extent because he wants
to have the lowest bounty right now he
wants to be underestimated shanks
himself warned white beard about
Blackbeard and said that the scars black
beard gave shanks weren't the result of
the red-haired young Co being careless
yes Blackbeard didn't just wreck ace as
soon as the fight started but I hope
everyone understands that that's normal
for one piece as we've seen fights
against strong opponents lasts longer in
one piece than another shows but
Blackbeard still won which is the
important thing and that was before he
had white beards gudaguda know me since
be the strongest paramecia fruit ever
black beard carried al-qaeda's plan when
he finished off white beard and then it
even better because he stole the opie
devil fruit and he's the only one to
ever possess more than one based on the
info available kaito is still the safer
bet one on one but I don't think it
would be an easy fight and ultimately I
believe that Blackbeard is underrated
and the most dangerous Yong Co because
of his Machiavellian strategizing right
now Kaido
is a drunk mentally unstable and weirdly
more honourable than you'd expect at
times he did not like the fact that the
clone clone crew was used to catch on
and off guard even though it meant his
victory he insisted that his men free
big mom from the sea stone chains so
that they could have a fair one I want
fight in contrast Blackbeard is
meticulous in his planning and will do
whatever it takes to get what he wants
just think about when he teamed up with
his whole crew to finish off an injured
and sick white beard was it honourable
no but it didn't bother Blackbeard for a
second this is what's so dangerous about
Blackbeard he's strong intentional and
will stoop to doing whatever it takes so
while Kaido might win one on one now
Blackbeard seems to be on the up-and-up
volcanoes drunkenness and carelessness
seems to be foreshadowing his defeat I
strongly believe that another Yong ko is
gonna show up if not all of them if
Kaito and big mom's alliance holds up
and one doesn't betray the other in
order to
a powerful opponent when shanks was
young and met Odin he offered to help
him in any way he could well I think
this upcoming war will definitely give
Yakko shanks an opportunity to help by
assisting Luffy and the others with
carrying out Odin's final wishes plus
you know that Blackbeard is not the kind
of guy to miss an opportunity to help
take out an opponent as powerful as
kaito and he's probably not gonna get a
better opportunity than this
keep in mind Moria is with him right now
and he's been itching to get revenge on
Kaito for decades coincidence I don't
think so and so I think it's totally
reasonable to assume that Kaito is the
strongest living character one-on-one
given the evidence we have so far but
even if it is the case it's not a big
gap between the other yakko and to yong
ko could definitely take him out luffy's
only chance of beating Kaito in my view
is for either big mom to betray him or
for him to get assistance from shanks
and/or fellow worst generation pirate
blackbeard
whatever happens I'm sure it will go
down as one of the most hyped and epic
Wars in the series if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep them coming show
one piece some love by smashing that
like button and sharing this video if we
can get six thousand likes
I repeat six thousand on this video I'll
get cert on the next strengths video
ASAP if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos and let me
know who you would like to see next
whether it's Blackbeard or someone else
in the comments if you guys keep wanting
to see these types of videos I can even
get to all of your suggestions
eventually I love making these videos
and will continue to do so as long as
you keep letting me know you want to see
more by smashing that like button and
sharing the videos lastly the YouTube ad
rates have significantly dropped
recently so the help and support we're
getting from our anime uproar patrons is
now more important than ever a very
special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legends acknowledged by Lord
we go himself baby Rey and Efrain a and
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans Stephen and Radha a Lola
attend o world Steelers the school bus
Tyson Kirino acquire respect at a hefyd
Jonathan King does Edie and Brandon of
aisles and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only yoga mat
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
I'll just Anatoly kazansky angel Cruz
team sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
Ted no Ted shelter Joe Stanton very
Gucci Alicia actor animal 69 jessica
calif on he no commie and water bonnie
parks is OD r12 wrath to Endora emperor
Taku JCC wakka the coach and according
to google translate the Chinese
characters for Emperor thank you all so
much and I love to see how global this
community has become if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon accomplish
anime outpour and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]